yes we all want to succeed yes adam
smith is correct and people at the end
of the day pursue
uh money in greed but if you really want
to rally the troops
if you really want to make a change it
starts from the spirit it starts from
liberal arts
it starts from the why why am i doing
what i'm doing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
we are in the aleph offices in tel aviv
and i'm joined today by michael
eisenberg
an equal partner at aleph an early stage
venture capital fund with over 500
million dollars under management
allah focuses on partnering with great
israeli entrepreneurs to build large
meaningful companies and impactful
global brands
since its founding in 2013 aleph has
invested in more than 40 companies
including melio lemonade bring joytunes
healthy io and xr
meet michael michael eisenberg how are
you doing good how are you
i would hit you with this hand but i
just got my cast and pin out
well thank you for treating me here at
the aleph offices
this is just beautiful i've been here
about six or seven years ago with lawn
and and
i'm friends with ed and i'm now i'm
friends with you so thank you for
inviting me and i'm excited to talk to
you about
your your amazing career both with
benchmark and with alex as an
as an amazing investor and thinker but
you're not just an investor you're a
father of six
no i'm a father of eight actually of
eight yeah we have to change the
linkedin
summary the blog wasn't scalable the
blog title wasn't scalable
i have to start by asking how do you get
everything done what
how do you think through your sort of
life or your day-to-day
because you do so much i've said this
before i don't believe
in this elusive notion of work-life
balance
i think it's uh it's a false promise we
make to people
nothing is ever in balance neither in
life nor in the world
we live in a constant state of imbalance
or are
out of balance and so i think what we
all actually strive to do is we try to
be the best in our family life which is
the most important obviously we try to
be
you know the best in our professional
life hopefully we try to be the best
in our charitable philanthropic uh life
and we try to merge all those we they
don't they're not separate islands
we try to merge them so something always
has to give
and i say to my kids all the time there
can only be one thing at the top of your
priority list at any given time
and you got to give your time to that
and so that's what you do
so how do i get things done i i don't
know um
but i give you the most important secret
to all that is i married really well
my wife's amazing and that's how i get a
lot done now do you still live in
jerusalem
i do i live in jerusalem we're in
rochelle in tel aviv if you have eight
children you're you're sitting
on the boards of some of the most
incredible companies in the world
uh and so something doesn't add up i
understand this idea of balance but it's
still then how do you just how do you
decide what do you do
they're sitting here with me how do you
decide what what is the priority i have
a schedule and then it gets out of
whack so i get up very early in the
morning i'm a morning person
um i'm in some bit of an insomniac like
i have a hard time sleeping
um i'm trying to get better at that it's
not going that well
the amount of energy and i get up early
i
i go to synagogue first thing in the
morning and then i sit down and i have a
bible at total study time because i've
been writing books i've just finished
i just published my fifth book wow and
i'm working on the sixth now
and so that's my morning time um
get my kids out along with my wife
although they're all kind of old enough
right now that they
more or less get themself out themselves
um
the younger three kids are living at
home the others have moved out for one
reason or another
and um and then i come to work in tel
aviv and you know do meetings i
i learn by meeting people and by doing
um
i read a fair amount but i i learn more
by meeting people and speaking
interesting people like you that's
that's how i learned so the more
meetings
the better so you're you've been an
internet investor since
95. since the dawn of the internet yeah
but i was planning on going that
direction but first i have to talk about
judaism and and values and waking up
every morning
you know with the tight schedule with
eight kids with all these investments
you still find time for for the things
that you're
that you're passionate about and you
believe in is does that con conflict in
any way
i think i think the world of values
morals ethics
and spirituality
is really what drives the human soul at
the end of the day
um yes we all want to succeed yes adam
smith is correct and people at the end
of the day pursue
money in greed but if you really want to
rally the troops
if you really want to make a change it
starts from the spirit it starts from
liberal arts
it starts from the why why am i doing
what i'm doing
um and and the why i'm doing what i'm
doing
uh goes back uh to a few things
uh one very important one is a
conversation i had
i was in like a press conference with a
rabbi many years ago and
what's funny is my wife would tell you
i'm not that into rabbis but
um he was a special man and and i once
asked him if i decided to move to israel
and i wasn't planning on it at the time
i was 20. i was 19 right before my 20th
birthday um
and i moved to like an unpopulated place
israel is about
the third the number of people as it is
now you know the negative the galilee
um where i moved to jerusalem in tel
aviv a big city is that kind of the same
uh the same uh reason or raise on the
echo to move or you look at me says it's
all nonsense
that's nonsense um you need to move to
israel
and build a factory that will employ 10
000 people to earn an honest and decent
living
and i said whoa that is a spiritual
reason for economic development
yeah people need to earn an honest and
decent living and at that moment i
decided to move to israel
and i would i would create ten thousand
jobs that's become
you know my life goal and if we get to
ten thousand we'll create a hundred
thousand jobs so people can earn an
honest and
decent living and that is a spiritual
calling
um in my view and one that needs to be
buttressed and undergirded
with with with ethics morals and values
and spirituality
because that's how bonds are formed
bonds are not they're formed by working
together i write about this in my most
recent book when we work together we
toil together when we build something
together
we form bonds but we also need a values
layer underneath it to be
able to sustain and nourish those bonds
well well i think just by looking at
just three or four of the companies that
are immediately jumping into my head
you've already
created many more than 10 000 honest and
decent jobs
in the state of israel and the world in
general i'll tell you a funny story at
the rabbi's 80th birthday party
i never talked about this until then
never and they asked me to come tell the
story of his 80th birthday it wasn't a
party it was like a big lecture it's
like 2
000 people in the audience all those
former students and i get up there and i
see he's got like this
smile this mischievous smile on his face
and i get up and i tell the story
and he looks at me says new how many
jobs have you created and i said
i don't think ten thousand he says well
get down from the stage and get back to
work
so amazing yeah and so when you
going back 26 years it's 1995.
what do you think to yourself do you do
is this the vision
where we are right now oh i don't know
you know the talmud says that that since
the temple was destroyed
there is no prophecy and anyone who
tries to prophesy is a fool
so i don't think we knew you know 95
what this internet was going to become
uh the first investment i made and
entered a company called picture vision
was for photo sharing it was a values
thing
i had moved to israel my family was
living in america my wife's family was
living in america
we had a young daughter how are you
going to share pictures and i said well
if i need this more people need this the
world's getting bigger
and so we can do this and help people
connect to their families
and uh you know we thought it turned
into a decent business it turned into a
good exit before i got a chance to turn
into a decent business because that was
that was the bubble
um and you know the early internet
conferences were like amazing there was
a guy named dick schaefer
um i can't he had a newsletter based out
of new york i can't remember the name of
the newsletter
right now but he ran this uh uh
conference i'll never forget in
burlingame first place i met eric
schmidt when he was still at sun
microsystems he was pitching java there
were multiple standards you know
amazing ethernet had one or whatever was
there was atm there was all this and uh
and everything was kind of mashed
together there was the networking
equipment there was
we didn't have to call the applications
or websites the yahoo guys were there
a couple years later bill gurley my
partner later benchmark and mary meeker
put on something called the internet
summit
yeah we knew everyone there there was
like i don't know how many people not
that many people there a couple hundred
people there i think it was in laguna
niguel
and uh and you knew everybody because it
was a small club and now it's everything
that's it's the one
yourself in the club i made this
investment in this company and we got an
investment
i did i did the first round it was a
story of itself
the angel round and then benchmark and
oak
did the second one a guy named ed
glassmeyer at oak and and first valve
and then bob kegel at benchmark
and so i got to meet people because he
walked around talking about pictures on
the internet
and it was like a novelty we got invited
to conferences but the internet
how does it oh how did i know that so
this is this is 1995.
you're saying that everybody knows
everybody how does how does michael
enter this brand new thing that that
just happens to explode later on so
i had the benefit of not knowing
anything about anything
uh and so i get to israel i'm in the
tech business because i was unemployed
that's a longer story that we have time
for in a 20-minute
thing so i was unemployed i couldn't get
a job i started something that became
like a merchant bank for tech we had no
money
we had some fees college and i
um and we we backed picture vision the
thing
so everyone looked at this company
picture version the early days of the
internet and said what's an internet
in israel because in 94 you kind of had
the internet in the us
the end of 94 beginning 95 but israel
hadn't really gotten here yet
my advantage was that when i was in
college
we were a beta site for this thing
called desktop publishing
we use something called aldus pagemaker
which i don't know if it exists anymore
to publish our colleges
because we had no money self-respecting
college newspapers like the harvard
crimson
wouldn't wouldn't use this thing at the
time and so we got a grant
actually to try this thing out we sent
it over 2400 baud modem and prayed that
call waiting wouldn't happen because
that dropped the line
and we'd send the paper from where we
were 186 in amsterdam avenue in
manhattan
down to fit on 17th street we said we
used to press
send hook up the modem press send say a
prayer that it wouldn't fall
wow get up pray the next morning in
synagogue in in
in yeshiva university and then take the
subway downtown to 17th street to go see
that the
paper had landed there so i knew what
this thing kind of was even wasn't
called the internet at the time
wow and that was an advantage here
amazing
so you're with benchmark and then you're
and then your transition also to aleph
and you're doing both yeah that's later
i joined benchmark in o5
yeah and so as you go through the years
yeah what's changed so
three things have changed um
there's a lot of things that have
changed but but one is i'm able to
articulate today something i
felt many years ago which is i think in
the 21st century
values generate value we may not agree
on what those values are
different you know maybe climate change
it may be financial inclusion it may be
creating jobs
but but brands in the 21st century are
being built around
values so values create value and
therefore i think
you know my my attachment to
spirituality into judaism
uh is an advantage in that i can
articulate that as
an economic uh value and economic
policy decision i'm in the middle of a
back and forth with an israeli economist
right now
as to whether um having children
is good for the economy or bad for the
economy right now israel's 3.1 births
per family
it's very clear in my view that having
children is good for the economy on
three vectors
one is demographic growth increases
demand number two young people drive
innovation that's very clear and number
three having children brings optimism
and optimism matters a lot for the
economy and for a society
i'll argue that part of what's going on
in the western world right now is the
decline in birth rate it's not just
harming the economy it's
harming optimism about the future what's
amazing to me as i'm hearing you is that
you know these are words that are not
being said you know i don't think by
innovative economists or
by critical thinkers about about you
know whether one one thing is good or
not
you're talking about a an intrinsic
value and you know a
sort of a morphic idea a theoretical
idea of optimism right
it's not theoretical at all i mean many
uh
economists like um like uh kahanamen
yeah have proven i don't think it's an
accident by the way kohanim studied in
the yeshiva when he was younger and came
to this point of view about the
psychological impacts on economic
decisions
um and and so
i'll say something a bit harsh right now
which is um economists don't have skin
in the game investors do
and so i'm judged by my outcomes
and if i'm wrong i'm out of business and
so i need to bet on that
innovation and that trend so that's kind
of yes it would change so that's one
thing that's changed the second thing
that's changed is
i know a lot more people now that i did
then and i know that the most important
thing
in your career is your network not your
knowledge
um you can learn lots of things that
benchmark did the same learner roles not
know it alls
but but being a mensch treating people
right
and building a network a reciprocal
network of i'll help you if you help me
is the most valuable thing you can do
early in your career
um what is being a mensch in the tech
industry for you what does that mean
you know tech industry is super
competitive and you need to
on everything for talent for ideas et
cetera
i think one is you need to draw lines
what you do but more importantly than
that
far more importantly is what will you do
for somebody else
one of the things that most inspired me
is we had a company here called gigia
that was attacked by the free syrian
army group of hackers
and we had a kind of competitor in
israel they sent their guys who came out
of the same army unit
that you did to go help us defend
ourselves against the
attackers that to me is amazing
that that's a values-based system that's
got strong
strong roots and so i think just turning
up for people
and building relationships is part of
being a mess with professor rooseveth
cantor
at harvard who's professor of leadership
says i think accurately that kind of the
first thing for leadership is turning up
and so many people don't turn up um you
know it's easy to turn up on twitter and
write 240 characters it's difficult to
turn up in person
yeah and so uh i think that's
so network really matters and i i i know
that in retrospect i think
the third thing that's that's changed
for me and this is i guess a privilege
at this point
um is i turned 50 this last week
and i really for the last bunch of years
to decide
i really only want to work with people i
want to work with yeah and so
i you know there could be the best idea
in the world if we're not going to enjoy
talking and not going to have a dialogue
just not interested
and i'm sure there are a lot of great
companies that will be built with people
who i
prefer not to hang out with and that's
totally cool i'll stand by i'll take a
walk
i'll take a ball it's fine i don't have
an anti-portfolio
because i don't think about that right
i'm sure i missed a ton
yeah so what i'm hearing you know
between the lines here it
all comes back to values it comes back
to this idea of why are we doing what
we're doing
and it doesn't matter whether it's an
it's an investor it's an entrepreneur or
whether
it's a it's in a garbage truck it's the
same idea that we're at the end
you know there's a hierarchy of needs
and there's a value system where
camaraderie the soul matters soul
matters
you need a brain it's the most powerful
organ in the body but the soul
matters and everybody has a soul
otherwise people wouldn't be offended
right that's right what have you learned
about
through the entrepreneurs that you that
you've worked with you've worked with
both you know
early and early very young entrepreneurs
with serial entrepreneurs you've seen
them grow
and running businesses employing
thousands of people
yeah um why matter is
simon sinek says is why matters more
than what why are we doing this
um you can get people to do extreme
things if
you explain to them why um and in
today's environment
where engineers are the scarce resource
they want to work on hard impactful
problems
and so why matters a lot that's also a
shift that's been happening no
question no question it's accelerating
my view um
so that's uh that's
that's in my view super important now
when i walk in
and and i immediately as i walk through
the door now if i see why speaking to
walking through the door like our motto
is exactly that different is better than
better
right which is we try to do things
differently here right
yeah i'm walking and i'm saying you
stand on the on the right
yeah bright pink shirt yeah and like
something
you know for a young person i cubicle i
don't even think about even the cubes i
think of it as that for me cubicles
dilbert i don't do that
i don't think i've even seen that in the
real world but
but i'm walking in here and i'm trying
to think you know
there's something in the energy here
that's different there's something
in the i don't know what it is when you
created alef
and you're thinking through alex's
vision and you've been here for it's
been quite for quite some time
yeah what what is alif so last night we
had a goodbye party for our office
manager who's been with us almost a
decade
wow and her name is zainab and she's the
heart and soul of olive
and we call her the chief happiness
officer at olive and she's been with me
since before all started um now here's
an amazing thing
all the olive employees since the
beginning of all turned up last night
for enough
really and so when we started olive what
we talked about ed and i is we wanted to
create a family
not just a venture firm and so
families have certain values one is you
stand up for people
and you prefer their interests over your
own so
we have a number of olive employees who
have gone on to our portfolio companies
who have gone on to better and bigger
careers and we've supported them in that
in a pretty meaningful way number two
you turn up for people personally not
just professionally so the lines here
between
professional and personal or more
blurred than what i think the
western bon-ton would like you to have
and i think that's very israeli by the
way which is
um and so you know we turn up for
people's happy occasions and their sad
occasions and if they need family and
you know
we're the family and so that's
super important to us and three since
day one
uh ed and i decided now uh our other
partner is aaron yael
tomer that um
we were going to invest in the broader
ecosystem and
and even if it wasn't an olive company
we were going to make this ecosystem
bigger
on the notion from an investment
perspective that a rising tide lifts all
boats
on a values perspective that the
robustness of this ecosystem as a whole
in our small country matters a lot and
so we've given out free content free
seminars
we make a lot of our stuff available to
people outside of our portfolio
um and so that's been a huge value and
our team is motivated by that
and i think our team if you ask them
thinks they're on a mission to you know
make israel and the israeli tech
ecosystem
unbelievably uh powerful and successful
we're talking about a bigger picture
here yes it's all about bigger pictures
you know this is the why
why are we doing this well we do this to
make money for our lps that's our
fiduciary duty
but we have a human duty a national duty
a brotherhood duty to help other people
and that's
that's a duty it's not a right it's a
duty
we took a lot we talk a lot more here
about duties and responsibilities than
we do
rights i'm not a giant believer in
rights
i don't think rights come without
responsibilities michael
there's ten more questions today that
i'm just beginning to
to think about but i it's 20 minutes and
then i know how busy i know i have to
get back to
to making the country better in the
world better but i do have to be in my
portfolio companies
yeah yes i have three uh fun questions
yeah about you
favorite subject in middle school or
high school
i wasn't in class that much but it was
probably english writing
english what were you doing outside of
class um
i was doing a lot of jewish outreach
across the united states and i
particularly worked with developmentally
disabled
at the time before they got the
definition right they were called
mentally
handicapped uh kids and i did that
up and down the east coast to start and
then in kind of the middle of the
country detroit cleveland columbus and
then the south miami atlanta savannah
and places like that so i
i was out a lot who would be somebody
that inspires you
as some sort of role model for you my
wife
that's easy that's easy yeah you know
and
my parents and my grandfather who we
discussed before we started doing
this who i was super close with and was
an officer in the u.s navy in world war
ii it was just a man of
extreme integrity and duty just
unbelievable
yeah i'm still going back to that to the
letter yeah and
three from 1945 1945 things don't change
yeah
and uh three words you would use to
describe yourself
if i were to ask eden
i don't know who's michael i don't know
it's uh the one thing i would say i'm
just
i feel deeply grateful to the people who
have helped me
uh along the way um
starting with my parents who decided to
have me that's actually for maybe a
broader conversation it's a story come
out around my 50th birthday i've known
it but my parents told it finally
it was not a trivial decision and
so super grateful
second is ambitious
which is i think i just turned 50 as i
mentioned there's a lot more to do in
this world
that that i'd like to do to make it a
better place
for our people and for the people of the
world
everyone deserves a shot and number
three
optimistic i'm always optimistic i can
see it in your eyes honestly
it's pretty amazing michael thank you
you